vous remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à l'heure des tno d'abord
quel regard vous portez sur cette trêve
conclue cette nuit entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan est ce qu'on peut espérer
qu'elle soit durable
c'est dès midi au pic et c'est la raison
saluant fort la fédération pour un
niveau de mise
ceci est un peu un cessez-le-feu
temporaire à en croire le président
azerbaïdjanais ça pourrait être le cas
également puisqu'il s'est montré très
ferme avant à ces négociations il a
affirmé je cite nous retournerons de
toute façon sur nos terres à ce que
c'est
c'est visiblement le signe d'une reprise
inéluctable des combats tôt ou tard le
président de commission mais ils se
trouvent pour je suis parti
la défense du haut karabagh il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui 12 ou 13 jours après
l'armée azerbaïdjanaise n'a pas beaucoup
avancé et messieurs aliev naturellement
quand il accepte le cessez-le-feu
france et grande considération également
cet élément se la font une fois de plus
que le conflit du haut karabakh n'a pas
de solution militaire
c'est ce que nous avions dit dès le
départ et ses spurs et c'est le cas
toujours encore aujourd'hui le conflit
du karabagh ne pas avoir de solution
militaire
alors les négociations doivent se
poursuivre pour à pérenniser ce cessez
le feu
quelles seraient les conditions pour
parvenir à un compromis selon vous pour
nous la ligne rouge sont très simples à
comprendre
une fois encore cette guerre a démontré
que
la population arménienne du haut
karabagh ne peut pas être mis sous le
giron de l'azerbaïdjan à tel point cette
population est menacée quand
l'azerbaïdjan pendant 12 jours
bombardent la population des impacts sur
6 10 on ne peut pas remettre tout aux
populations à la merci d'un pouvoir
autoritaire de pouvoir meurtrier qu'est
l'azerbaïdjan
ça c'est le premier point le haut
karabagh l'indépendance du haut-karabakh
doit être reconnu premier point et
deuxième point la sécurité de cette
opération doit être garanti par des
mécanismes internationaux oms guevorkian
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions on
va devoir réduire raccourcir cette
interview puisque la liaison et est très
mauvaise je rappelle que vous êtes
représentant du haut karabagh en france
merci pour cet éclairage